Game of Thrones season 6 episode 9 let's
have a look
marine is under siege by the slavers
Daenerys speaks with Tyrion and he says
the city is doing quite well apart from
the hole being bombarded with flaming
rocks [ __ ] Dany is unimpressed and
declares she will crucify the slavers
kill all their soldiers and destroy
their cities
she is embracing the role of a violent
vengeful dragon queen Tyrion plays the
angel on her shoulder suggesting that
wiping out whole cities might not be the
right thing to do he reminds her of the
madness and the cruelty of her father
Ares and tells her about his plan to
destroy King's Landing with wildfire
this is an important warning for Dany
hopefully she'll avoid becoming a
terrible tyrant like her father but is
also yet another hint that the wild fire
beneath King's Landing is still down
there just waiting for a Mad Queen to
set it off and burn the city so Danny
and koa go chat with the slavers they
demand that Dany surrender but they seem
to have forgotten that Dany has a
gigantic bloody dragon scratched that
three gigantic bloody dragons who fly in
the sky and the CGI looks sick meanwhile
the sons of the harpy up to their usual
shenanigans slaughtering civilians so
Danny's Dothraki and Daario right in to
sweep them away the whole thing with the
sons of the harpy has been weird this
season in episode one there seemed to be
a setup of a mystery to uncover who
their leader is but that never really
went anywhere apparently it's just been
the slavers funding them all along which
is hardly a surprise if you want to put
on your tinfoil hat some people theorize
that Varys has secretly been behind the
harpy all this time as a way of pushing
Dany to leave marine and go to Westeros
sooner and it is curious that Varys has
never once met Danny this whole season
this poll series but it's probably
nothing
so Danny's dragons fly around and burn a
slaver ship they leave most of the ships
untouched because Danny wants to capture
the slaver Navy not wipe it out and this
is really the first time we've seen
adult dragons used in war and they do
seem so destructive and unstoppable just
imagine what these monsters would do to
the armies of Westeros hopefully we'll
soon see
but yeah the slavers are basically
screwed so grey worm lets their soldiers
go free but missandei says that one of
the slavers must die the two highborn
guys gang up on the lowborn say to kill
him but in a kind of King Solomon
fashion grey worm kills the
- and let's the lowborn years and go to
warn his slaver friends of the power of
Daenerys Targaryen over in Westeros
outside Winterfell the Starks confront
the Bolton's ramsay brings Lords umber
and Karstark while Jon brings Sansa and
Davos in torment in liana so it's pretty
clear who's got the cooler squad the two
sides threaten and taunt each other it
doesn't really go anywhere just setting
the stage for the fight that is to come
back at Camp the Starks strategize and
things don't look good they just don't
have enough men but they devise a plan
as best they can Sansa gets mad at Jon
for not asking her what to do so he asks
her what to do and she says she doesn't
know what to do but she does give him
some really good advice she says that
Ramsay toys with people baits them and
traps them she warns him not to do what
Ramsay wants him to do which comes up
later on then we see Davos talking with
tormund they find common ground in that
they both served failed kings devil
served King Stannis and torment served
the king-beyond-the-wall Mance Rayder
they figured Jon might be a better man
to follow because he's not a king funny
thing is that there's lots of fish
shadowing in the books and the show that
Jon may become a king maybe sooner than
we think but then John visits Melisandre
they chat about her God and while Mel's
pretty sure that God has a plan for us
all she says it might not be a nice one
there's a sense of resignation here a
feeling that everything might go
terribly wrong but that there's nothing
anyone can do to stop it John tells Mel
not to bring him back if he dies in
battle it would have been nice to have
seen more of Mel this season episode 1
had that revelation of an ancient age
which seemed to set up for some
exploration of a character but we never
really got any we do know though that
she'll have a role in episode 10 because
when Davos goes a walking he finds the
wooden stag he carved Fischer een the
little girl who was burned by Mel last
season Davos loved Shireen like a
daughter he's going to want justice for
her which means Mel might face dire
consequences
back in Moran Yara and Theon arrived to
meet Daenerys it would have been cool to
have actually gotten some shots of the
Ironborn sailing in in the midst of
battle as is happening in the books but
whatever the Greyjoy's are now here and
we start with Tyrion attacking Theon for
having been rude to him in season 1
which is weird because it was actually
mostly Tyrion being rude to Theon
so maybe Tyrion just
as a bad memory Danny complains about
their respective shitty dad's Aries for
Danny Thailand for Tyrion Balaam for
euro and Theon and there's a strong
feminist undertone here between Danny
and Yara and ilaria and Sansa women are
now taking power in usually
male-dominated Westeros Yara hits on
Danny which gives the shippers and fan
figures something to squeeze out and
ultimately they agree to work together
Danny will help you our attack the Iron
Islands and Yara will help Danny take
Westeros Danny's one condition is that
the Ironborn stop raiding and reeving
and stealing [ __ ] from the other
kingdoms which is not a super realistic
demand because as Yara says that's the
Ironborn way of life can they really be
expected suddenly reinvent their whole
culture tony has the same problem with
the Dothraki when these guys wage war
they rape and pillage and Dany can't
reasonably expect that too quickly or
easily change when Danny invades
Westeros she's bringing foreign sell
swords she's bringing Dothraki screamers
she's bringing Ironborn Reavers and some
she assumes are good people
but if she's expecting all these groups
to just happily get along with the
Westerosi after she takes over she is
gonna have a bad time back in Westeros
the stark and Bolton armies faceoff
Ramsay uses recon as bait to draw out
Jon and Jon being a brave hero and a
bloody idiot who didn't listen to Sansa
rides right into Ramsay's trap only for
Rickon to get hit at the last minute
from an olympic-level
archery shot from Ramsay Rickon really
didn't do much this season didn't have a
single line he just turned up looked sad
then died but there's still a lot of
hope that he'll be awesome in the books
he's apparently hanging out with OSHA
and shaggy-dog on an island of cannibals
and unicorns but yeah now Jon stuck out
in the open so Ramsay activates his trap
card sending his cavalry out to squash
Jon and giving us easily one of the
coolest shots in the series with Jon
standing and facing the enemy looking
ready for a second death but the stark
forces ride up behind him and then we
get this crazy intense combat scene with
horses and soldiers and swords and blood
and mud flying every which way it's
pretty stunning the violence is brutal
and chaotic and exciting and sickening
all at once Ramsay keeps firing arrows
Davos and small Jon join in and the
bodies pile up until ramsay surrounds
the stark forces with Bolton shields he
has sprung and
the trap as the boltons closed in 1:1
does a surprisingly bad job of trying to
break free tormund mike tyson's small
john and things start getting a bit too
cozy with John almost crushed by the
massive bodies in a shop reminiscent of
Daenerys at the end of season 3 but
without the uncomfortable racial imagery
then when all hope seems lost to the
Knights of the Vale right in to save the
day like the Rohirrim at Helm's Deep
except instead of being led by gandalf
they're led by Littlefinger a decidedly
less trustworthy Ally Ramsay retreats to
Winterfell Jon gives chase one one
breaks the gate and is killed by an
arrow from Ramsay which is actually
super tragic because as far as we know
1/1 is the last of his species along
with the children of the forest this is
the second apparent extinction of the
season the two native inhabitants of
Westeros are now as far as we know
totally gone there are bits about this
in the books it's like Lord of the Rings
type deal with the old races of magic
and nature disappearing and being
replaced by the world that men have made
here's a sad little song sung by
wildlings eulogizing the Giants so Jon
punches Ramsay in the face 21 times and
Ramsay somehow not only survives but is
left with a face that still looks like a
face just got some red paint on it which
feels kind of silly really but
regardless the Starks now have
Winterfell which pleases Mel because she
foresaw this long ago I have seen myself
walk along the battlements of Winterfell
I have seen the flayed man banners
lowered to the ground what Mel doesn't
know is that Davos is eying her he wants
justice Fisher rein and there's a really
cool way this could go down it may be
that Mel will be put to death for the
murder of Shireen so Jon might execute
Mel and if he does his sword may be set
alight with Mel's in a fire transforming
it into Lightbringer The Flaming Sword
of azor Ahai the hero prophesied to save
the world from the White Walkers this
might not be likely at least in the show
but it would be pretty sick the Starks
have recovered richens body even though
those cavalry charges should have
reduced it to a bloody slurry and Jon
says he'll bury the body in the
Winterfell crypts and this is exciting
because there's heaps of mystery and
foreshadowing surrounding these crypts
Ned and bran and Rickon and especially
John all have
rheems of the crypts fans believe that
some secret deep inside relating to r+ l
equals J's so probably with the help of
brans visions next episode were almost
certainly finally going to get
confirmation of John's true parentage
then we have the final scene of the
episode with Sansa killing Ramsay by
feeding him to the same dogs that he
used to kill others you could call that
poetic justice but in a weird way Ramsay
wins here before he dies Ramsay tells
Sansa that he's part of her now and some
people think that means that Sansa is
pregnant or something but what this
really means is that Ramsay changed
Sansa from someone gentle and
compassionate to someone sadistic and
cruel like him because it is sadistic to
have someone eaten alive by dogs and to
enjoy it to watch it and smile at
someone else's horrific suffering that's
not the stark way that's not what Ned
would have done clean and honorable and
respectful feeding someone to dogs and
watching for pleasure is exactly the
sort of thing that Ramsay would do by
inflicting this revenge Sansa has
stooped down to his level
she has allowed herself to be consumed
by the same blood thirst that she hated
in Ramsay she killed him but she allowed
his cruelty to become part of her so who
rules the North now with Rickon dead and
bran still believed dead and Jon still
believed a bastard
Sansa should now be the head of House
Stark but Littlefinger is the one with
the power here right he controls the
biggest army and we know that he wants
to rule the north last season he makes a
deal with Cersei to name him warden of
the north if he takes Winterfell
so maybe Littlefinger will take
Winterfell from the Starks and rule the
north himself or maybe he'll want to
marry Sansa join his power to hers and
rule the north together maybe that was
Sansa's plan all along maybe that's why
she didn't tell Jon about the Knights of
the Vale cuz if she just told Jon that
she had an army coming he wouldn't have
had to rush into that losing battle he
could have just waited for the Knights
of the Vale to arrive and saved
thousands of northern lives maybe Sansa
wanted this maybe she planned to have
the armies of the North destroy each
other so that she and Littlefinger could
mop up and be sure to have Winterfell to
themselves
and maybe Sansa still hasn't forgiven
Littlefinger for having given at a
Ramsey and for being a manipulative
scheming creep generally and will kill
him after taking power leaving her in
control with all the power as the warden
even the Queen in the north of course
it's not clear if Jon will be cool with
all this and given all the hints about
him and kingship given the probable
revelations about his parentage next
episode it may be that he'll make some
claim as the king in the North or even
of Westeros so this could go a bunch of
ways with Littlefinger Sansa and John
all vying for power the situation in
Mereen of course is clearer with the
defeat of the slavers Danny's power is
now unquestioned she's got her three
dragons a Toth rocky her unsullied
second sons I am born with all their
ships Danny now has what she needs to
sail west to Westeros the only likely
complication left is you wrong
so yeah this episode was pretty awesome
it plays to the strengths of the show
because the show is sometimes bad with
plot and character but what it really
does well is spectacle these shots of
dragons above marine and the Battle of
Winterfell are stunning and something
you can never get from a book so for all
the shortcomings of the show it is still
great TV and we're really lucky to see
this story in both mediums so that's 9
episodes down one to go
thank you all for watching so far and
special thanks to all the patrons for
supporting this channel on patreon
including philip bond my rain sad a
mohammed al carbee Johanna Kamla Mindy
Rossetto Katie Murphy Sephora Rothschild
Jacob Zak's Mona Pangea Elizabeth from
Michael Howie and Dirk Cheers
you